from science mission I am going to
highlight some of the scientific
research that is making news in the last
24 to 48 hours in addition to the
phosphate provided by fungal hyphae
researchers in the journal PNAS found
that the plants colonized by micro
raschel fungi have a different gene
expression this causes the cell walls
within ground roots to soften figuring
the growth of many more lateral roots
which are able to second more nutrients
contributing to a healthier rice plant
with a higher yield next the researchers
in the journal Obesity found significant
increase in our genus activity within
the blood vessels and in blood of obese
rats compared to lean animals the
destruction of arginine by our genus
releases nitric oxide levels leading to
the construction of blood vessels and
high blood pressure supplementing
arginine in the diet are blocking our
Genesis activity reversed hypertension
in obese rats next in a paper published
in pianist the animals exposed to noise
similar to that made by a lawn mower or
hair dryer for a week the animals
auditory nerve cells change their
structure enlarging their nerve endings
where neurotransmitters are stored and
discharging a smaller proportion of
their neurotransmitter reserves in
response to stimuli when researchers
place the noise exposed mice into a
quiter habitat the animals auditor in
ourselves adapted once again to new
conditions for more details visitors at
www.hsn smishing facebook page thanks
for what